In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion, for May 6th, on which we commemorate the Holy and
much-suffering Prophet Job.
On the sixth day of the month we celebrate the memory of righteous Job.
Long before the coming of Christ and his proclamation of the promises of eternal life,
we are lived in the country of Austidia, on the border of Idhumia and Arabia, a just
and upright man named Job, who feared God and kept himself from all evil.
He was the wealthiest of all the sons of the East and possessed numbers of flocks and
servants, yet he used his wealth in the service of God.
One day, Satan presented himself before God, after having roamed the earth to see whom
he could devour and lead along his own wicked path.
When God showed him Job, as an example of a just and upright servant, the devil replied
with an evil, cold irony, that it was easy for this rich man to remain faithful to God.
Bonding to this jive, the Lord put all Job's possessions in Satan's power.
Sometime afterwards, messengers approached the patriarch to break the news of the loss
of his flocks and the violent death of all his sons and daughters.
Job thereupon tore his garments, shaved his head as a sign of mourning, and prostrated himself
on the earth, pronouncing these memorable words.
Naked came eye out of my mother's womb.
Naked shall I return thither.
The Lord gave and the Lord has taken away.
Blessed be the name of the Lord.
Thus God was able to point out to Satan that his servant Job had remained faithful in his
misfortune.
But the devil by no means confessed himself defeated and said, touch his bone and his flesh,
and I swear to thee he will curse thee to thy face.
God is not the author of evil nor does he delight in suffering, but he permitted that his
servant be afflicted from head to foot by ulcers to test his virtue.
The rich and powerful patriarch, having become the laughing stock of all, took a pottery
shard, scraped his wounds, and sat himself down on a dung heap outside the village.
When his wife urged him to curse God, he replied, thou speakest as one of the foolish women.
What, shall we receive good at the hands of God, and shall we not receive evil?
The news of Job's misfortune came to the ears of three of his wise and noble friends from
towns of the east.
Eli Faz, from Teaman, Bill Dad, from Shua, and Zofar, from Nehemathe.
They came to console him, but, seeing him on his dung heap, they broke into sobs, and
for seven days were not capable of pronouncing a single word.
It was Job who finally spoke, to curse the day of his birth, and to wish for his death.
That would put an end to all his woes.
Hearing the complaint of the just man who suffers, Eli Faz put forth the usual argument of
human reason seeking to explain such affliction.
Suffering and misfortune are sent by God to punish former sins.
That Job not protest the integrity of his conduct to justify himself before God, but rather
let him confess his sins and repent.
Thus obtaining forgiveness, and the restoration of his health and prosperity, revolt against
his lot could only bring further misfortune.
The wise man added that human beings are made to suffer, and that the sins and injustices
we commit in this life must be punished.
Instead of consoling Job, these words troubled him and increased his suffering.
He reproached his friends for their hardness in his regard.
For those who have not been tested cannot comprehend the suffering of the innocent, tried in the
fires of tribulation, and thus once more proclaimed his own innocence.
After being in revolt against God, nor asking to be delivered from his misfortune, Job expressed
only the desire for death to bring an end to it all.
When his only consolation would be never to have opposed the word of God.
Then Bill-dead interrupted him, to take up the same argument as his companion, and expressed
a general abstract law on retribution for evil actions, which, however, did not apply
to Job's case.
God is absolutely just.
Job, therefore, should not protest his innocence, but implore God's mercy.
Job replied that it was certainly possible to say that the misfortune that comes to us
is a punishment for sin.
But what creature could ever be found righteous before Almighty God?
Even if a person could see nothing with which to reproach himself, as in his own case, he
could not justify himself, and would see himself handed over to tribulation just like the wicked.
And addressing God, he added, thou knowest that I am not wicked, and that there is none that
can deliver out of thine hand.
Seize then and let me alone, that I may find a little joy before I go once I shall not return,
even to the land of darkness and the shadow of death, where light never penetrates, and
the life of men is never to be seen.
It seemed then to Job that, from then on, he could scarcely count on the understanding of
his friends, who put themselves forward as defenders of divine justice by untruthful
accusations against him, and so taking his flesh in his teeth, and putting his life in his
hands, he questioned God in anguish.
How many are mine iniquities and sins?
Make me know my transgressions and my sin.
Wherefore hideous thou thy face.
After a second intervention by Ellie Faz, who accused him of rising up against providence,
Job, seeing that his friends were becoming his persecutors, cried out, have pity on me, have
pity on me, oh ye my friends, for the hand of God has struck me.
Why do you persecute me as God?
Then, setting aside his complaint, he confessed his hope, a hope as yet undefined, one with
that of all the righteous of the Old Testament.
I know that my Redeemer liveth, and that he shall stand at the latter day upon the earth,
and though after my skin warms destroy this body, yet in my flesh shall I see God.
Unfeeling and implacable in their zeal to defend their conception of divine justice, the
three sages again took up their charge against the just, no longer contenting themselves with
the generalities, but enumerating in detail the sins Job must have committed during the
time of his prosperity to warrant such a chastisement.
Job maintaining before and against them all the witness of his conscience demanded to appear
before God to be judged, convinced that his cause would triumph, and that he would draw
consolation from God alone.
He then proclaimed in an admirable testimony that, if God's wisdom in creation is inaccessible
to human knowledge, it is not possible to know why the just are afflicted.
The just will not cease, however, to love God and to entrust themselves to him.
After this, he continued his discourse with a long defense of his own conduct, and proclaimed
that he was ready to give an account of all his acts, and to answer in public all the charges
that had been brought against him.
As the three sages remained silent, having produced all their arguments, Elihu, who had
been silent because of his youth, became angry with Job, who thought himself in the right
before God and was thus adding rebellion to his sin.
When Elihu became silent again, God himself spoke from the heart of the tempest, as he had
done in former times, on the summit of Mount Sinai.
In a wide sweeping discourse on the mysteries of creation and providence's governing of the
universe, which submits even monsters and natural catastrophes to its benevolent design, God
provided His servant Job with the key to the enigma, which human wisdom had not been able
to resolve.
His trials had not been sent as a punishment for sin, but by gracious and unfathomable design
in order to show forth His righteousness.
Will Thou reject my righteous judgment?
Does Thou judge that I acted other than to show forth Thy righteousness?
Realizing now that His tribulations were themselves a revelation of the incomprehensible, unfathomable,
and inaccessible God, Job at last declares, I had heard the report of thee by the ear before,
but now mine I have seen thee, wherefore I have counted myself vile and have fainted and
esteemed myself dust and ashes.
This humble confession was for Job the crowning of his virtue and access to a true knowledge
of God, which is none other than the sensing of His incomprehensibility.
Triumphing over His tribulation, He was filled with blessing as soon as He had interceded
at God's command to obtain forgiveness for the sins committed by His friends against Him.
The Lord restored His fortunes.
He gave Him a double portion of what He had possessed, a numerous descendants.
Job lived for another hundred and forty years and then died at the ripe old age of two hundred
and forty.
The book of Job occupies a unique place in Holy Scripture and has been the great consolation
of all the servants of God, put to the test in every age.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.